I don't think you have to make a choice
I think in the United States will always
have both together because as long as we
continue to believe in race kind of like
people believe in witches no matter how
often it gets disproved that will have a
kind of gut-level feeling for us that
the notion of class doesn't in Britain
for instance in England class has a
gut-level feeling but not in the United
States so they're not the same thing and
it's not either/or but you're absolutely
right to think that race is less
important when people are doing well so
it's not that somebody will look at
somebody who looks like me and say oh my
gosh you're white it said it won't
matter so much anymore
the American sense of the the importance
the fundamental importance of the
black/white dichotomy comes out of
societies founded in the era of the
African slave trade so societies like
ours that is to say the western
hemisphere the Caribbean and so forth we
share a lot in common in places like
Germany or France the idea of black
white is not so much black white but our
people and them and them can be people
from the near East like Turks or Muslims
or North Africans all of whom might well
be considered white in the United States